[Music]
hi welcome to another episode of cold
fusion
these were the winners of an ai
competition in 2020
frankly they're nothing groundbreaking
and what they're trying to depict is
barely coherent
looking at some more ai generated images
from back in 2020 it's amazing that in
just two short years we have
photorealistic imagery
while ai generated images have obvious
visual signs of improvement what many
people don't realize is that in the past
two years ai language models have also
drastically improved
in a previous episode we saw how a
google language model conversed so well
that one of google's engineers claimed
that the ai had become sentient
in another infamous case redditers were
fooled by an ai for months on end
over in the other corner we have boston
dynamics and in a smaller sense the
amica robot they've both shown us that
robots can indeed be made with human
dexterity
so you probably know where this is going
what if we happen to combine ai's new
understanding of language with a
physical robot body
well google has just done this and the
results are very interesting in this
episode we'll learn all about it and see
what could be in store for the future
[Music]
google research labs along with another
alphabet subsidiary called everyday
robots have teamed up to make a new kind
of robot
you see instead of carrying out
pre-programmed tasks this new robot can
understand a spoken task in natural
language and then do that task for you
this method removes the obvious
limitations of pre-programmed hard
coding and opens the door to a massive
amount of possibilities
to achieve this mission the team put one
of google's most advanced ai brains in a
robot body and when i say brain i'm not
using that word loosely
[Music]
a recent 2022 paper published in the
journal nature found something
interesting
when human brain patterns were measured
in experiments and compared to ai
language models there were some uncanny
similarities
particularly in the way both systems
process language specifically in the way
that they predict words from context in
addition to this their neural
activations mirror each other
the ai's internal activities quote
significantly map onto human brain
responses to written sentences
so it sounds weird but according to this
research we're beginning to learn that
ai language models are behaving like
human brains
kind of surprising but maybe it's just
the fact that technology is starting to
help us understand biology
so back to the robot
in summary the physical robot acts as
the language model's hands and eyes
while the language model supplies the
knowledge about the task at hand
to give an example a user can ask a task
i've spilt my drink the robot interprets
the sentence using the language model it
comes up with a bunch of solutions in
its software but only selects what it's
capable and best at doing it then
analyzes its environment to see how to
physically proceed
okay so what this couldn't have been
that hard to do right
well there's a lot of careful
engineering that had to be done to make
this possible
if you ask an ai language model a
question it will give you a sensible and
reasonable answer but that answer may
not be feasible or useful to the robot
for example if you say i've spilt my
drink the language model may tell you
you could try using a mop but if there
is no mob in the scene or if the robot
is incapable of using a mob the task is
impossible
google researchers managed to create a
way for the robot to understand what it
can and can't do but more on this later
ai computer vision was used to pair what
the robot is seeing with its vast
knowledge base from the internet the
robot can understand and complete a task
as complex as i spilled my orange soda
can you throw it away bring me something
to help clean it up and then bring me a
replacement so in all of this the key
here is that the machine ends up being
pretty open-ended it's general
industrial machines for example have to
be precisely programmed to do a very
specific task
[Music]
so how is understanding achieved
google research is using their palm
model in the robot
so what on earth is palm
palm stands for pathways language model
it's an algorithm that's been trained on
countless amounts of text from the
internet we're talking hundreds of
billions of parameters and petabytes of
text
the result of all of this training is
its ability to understand language
it's important to note that these types
of massive language learning models are
pretty new
only around two years old
the vast levels of training on billions
of parameters makes them vastly
different to services like siri or alexa
in addition to the palm model the
researchers used another system of code
to let the robot know what it can and
can't do this code called world
grounding trims out unsafe or nonsense
actions
machine learning is one of the few
things that we have that really makes it
possible to get computers to behave
intelligently in unstructured
environments
by using experience using data using
things that the computer's seen in the
past to figure out patterns
reinforcement learning is one of our our
big bets it's a machine learning
algorithm where each time the robot
attempts to do a task we can reward it
if it succeeds tell it that it didn't
succeed if it fails and then the things
that lead it to succeed get rewarded
more and more often and it gets better
and better at the task and this is
something we can do across many robots
at the same time to share that learning
and that experience
to speed up the learning process the
software was trained in a virtual world
so it could gain the benefits of
knowledge through a simulated
environment but without having to spend
mass amounts of time in the physical
world
we can really multiply our impact by
having the robots also practice how to
do things in simulation we can do things
like simulate many other buildings and
many other types of objects and many
other types of lighting conditions and
backgrounds
and what we've been able to do with the
simulator is significantly reduce the
amount of real world data that we've
needed on the order of going from about
500 000 attempts all the way down to
only needing 5 000 attempts to learn
grasping
we've seen this method before in the
episode about open ai and the dextrous
hand robot i thought it was a very
clever idea then
so finally the robot's world grounding
was tied into another section of code
that turns high-level instructions into
low-level subtasks that can then be
performed
once all of this is done you have a
robot that can understand and then
perform tasks without human intervention
and it does so better than anything else
out there at the moment
[Music]
in their paper google claims that the
language model and robot selects the
right sequence of skills 84 of the time
and executes them successfully 74
percent of the time
this is a 50 improvement over the
previous latest research
the computer scientists also state that
the performance keeps improving when the
language model does so this could get
much better pretty quickly
the team stated that the mobile robot
could accomplish a large set of abstract
instructions in a real kitchen with
objects it's never seen before
the significance here is that this is
the first time a large-scale model has
been used in a real-world robot it can
be seen as a hallmark in the field of
robotics
these findings suggest that the field of
robotics can benefit from the
improvements in language modelling this
could bring the two areas of research
closer together in the future
as for the robots 100 of them are doing
autonomous tasks around google's offices
it has to wander around buildings find
the trash cans look in them
understand what's in them and if
something's in the wrong bucket look in
those buckets robot and if you can move
it into the right bucket
the sorting experiment is really pushing
us to try and write an application that
improves by itself just through practice
is that going to work i hope so the way
we made it the tools and recipes we used
to create this pick an object out of a
bin capability we'll be able to use that
same recipe to learn a new skill
[Music]
the more we give the robots a problem
and they get better at it just by trying
to get better at it that's the thing
that will convince us that these robots
are now ready to go solve lots of
problems for people in their everyday
lives
[Music]
so that was kind of a lot to get your
head around but what does this mean for
the future of robotics
although it is a major milestone right
now google's robot is pretty slow at
completing tasks and can only grab basic
objects
but then we have to ask what about in 15
to 20 years
will we have to worry about physical
automation for entry level jobs like
fast food
taking into account the current pace of
advancements in both robotics and the
new ai that's starting to power them
this could be a strong possibility
but on the flip side there are plenty of
other use cases too
language model robots could be useful in
anything from aged care to growing food
or cleaning up dangerous waste and
pollution
robots like spot have already proven the
latter possible
in any case the future is definitely
going to be interesting
as for me in summary i wouldn't exactly
want one of these google robots in my
house but i definitely do see the value
in the research for certain situations
as a side if you're confused and asking
yourself
why is this all suddenly happening now
where did ai even come from and who
exactly invented ai you're in luck
because i've done a whole documentary on
it and you can check it out in the
description below i just think it's an
important story that adds a lot of
context to what's happening today
anyways that's about it from me my name
is dagogo and you've been watching cold
fusion if you did enjoy this episode
don't bother subscribing but instead
have a browse of this channel there's
plenty of interesting stuff on here
alright so i'll see you again soon for
the next episode
cheers guys
have a good one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
cold fusion
it's new thinking